I still feel shook yeah or lit oh no a
small or something whoa whoa ku woke now
cuz you're aware and you're a locust
[ __ ] awake to their genitals anyway
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to giraffes volleyball
championship 2016 goddamn evening yep
yeah yeah it's been a long day yesterday
we did all the meat people out in the
park kind of thing and we just got done
with genital jousting and McDonald's
didn't give us like half our food yeah
that's not true - so uh so did monster
us McDonald's give us all our [ __ ]
food anyway we decided to have a palate
cleanser with giraffes volleyball
champion [ __ ] looks so cute it is cute
it's cute
ah so we got this game because it looked
adorable and cool and if it looks like
something that might be very difficult
to do but in the same time rewarding oh
well well hi Hey well hey hi sorry
that's good hey I forgot some oh did you
take some weight over there yeah let's
go what's going on oh wait come back
what was it
hi I'm teddy oh hi hey okay that's
awesome face wait baby come back over
but you don't gotta have your head up
high you'd be a little little boy okay
all right you know I'm just gonna do
this this once this is a very difficult
elephant you know yeah oh sorry
that's good baby no wait sorry sorry
hang on wait wait what mmm okay see [ __ ]
is happening I wonder the whole game I
said resolution office adjust to this is
outside the thing on this note I think
something's happened oh my gosh is dad a
bug Oh
oh my god oh my god oh god I don't
notice but I think you're something Josh
whatever you score I think next or
something I don't know so that's what we
were doing before we're all true geez I
mean I appreciate them the depravity of
that scene no I feel a little chow down
here what do I need
Oh No what do I need you ball ball ball
really um oh oh oh god I have
accidentally keep doing that in common
yeah oh oh jesus oh my god I can get it
under your neck and release to slot it
down bully clip whoa whoa whoa oh boy is
an extra guy blacc walking what walk got
out zip OH
ball ball we could oh how the [ __ ] was I
supposed to [ __ ] here
all right okay you won't go best of
three
sure that's the three in then we'll
trade off Morgan oh Jesus Oh God
you bring a mask for this just glasses
whoo touchdown oh [ __ ] yeah no no no god
I'm so confident physics of the legs all
right I'm gonna try bounces on it
oh sorry oh whoa whoa jeez oh oh
Thrun eggs okay when you can't love the
lexer here we go again
Bob lazy serves my crazy boys let's
seize that man crazy
oh no your legs what what's up what what
all right
what what what what wizard you ever
wonder when my legs do these things week
ah [ __ ]
boy got in who's amazing sir that was
harsh
ah ah oh no like this is March for
babies for genital jousting yeah my
favorite game that I played in lo que se
really satisfying in a lot of ways
Oh for driving I this isn't too hard so
far wait how can you ask right up to the
edge of the screen and I can't you can't
that's why I fell between me and the
Waldo you can't what the [ __ ] was that
well it doesn't matter
yeah you can't go away Oh weights got
that D oh no oh yeah that would present
a distinct disadvantage yeah well what
are you supposed to do now you can't
[ __ ] egg ah there you go get on the
head there oh you didn't do it right
lovely oh good Oh balls
I can pretty synthetic hands I can just
stare in the wing the leg wall and be
really satisfied for a long time it's a
pleasant game delay time Punk maybe I
show you the down low light wobble it's
too long got lucky last night with me
you guys need some hype giraffes in the
background okay oh god it's night okay
oh God oh whoa you're not gonna need to
do anything else a body hit mark mostly
to study
I'm just trying to be fancy I just need
to let you uh [ __ ] talk that's all that
was my mistake I tried to play too much
you ready for this I think so yeah Wow
oh god oh god yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
trying to get it
oh I think it's best of three again
again good think it's better three good
mark
I have a family it's gonna go over these
okay yeah those trick shots though did
we take drugs or something
I feel really working right yeah they
the unbelievable jocks division oh no
luck summation of just having stopped
playing genital jousting and now playing
this it's just like I don't know what
life is anymore we chose in a weird day
yeah no it's just about those jarring
programming we have gone with for our
lesbian session this is so I think I
think this one this particular game
should be played ball arrogantly drunk
and or extremely I vote you know a
little bit with the music and the
aesthetic yeah did you play lovely
planet no I didn't it was like a first
big shooter that was like really really
loopy and you just run around and shoot
your love at enemies to do oh I did and
the music was a lot like this and you
were just like whew what do we look it
up it's made by the same developers that
would be mind-blowing because it is it's
got that similar vibe that I really like
mmm I mean I really appreciate it oh
it's just so hard to predict when it's
coming down I know the physics is all me
you sure a little chat I think yeah yeah
even something that I was yeah oh sweet
Moses that stupid wall it seems lessons
mean up oh oh leave your room I think
you better go back there to serve I'm
only redone get operated stay hit all
was really hoping he'll just fall that
he was just like [ __ ] it I want to say
this
whoa double trickshot
whoa nice trick I'm up here [ __ ] nice
trick oh dear
oh really my test was gonna get it huh
ha ha to be heavy but you did it you saw
me had me but me take this video to you
me ask me a question mmm oh that chest
bump is that walking missing mask so
that was our shows our trunk that was
the same walking dead me ask me
something ask me something you thought
you knew but you did not
Laurie ah Laurie [ __ ] yeah yeah just
[ __ ] to write it though you do now I'm
gonna beat you whoa I'm just a game
Oh Lord that was does not what you meant
to say it was relatively nodded oh wow
I'm saying I appreciate that
it wasn't like yesterday I only meant to
attack your skills now whoa I mean it
kind of hurt a little sorry nope I
always win the heads up because I am
clearly better and thicker chested Rick
can you do look at you nothing huh
nothing ha ha gotcha didn't I you got
nothing ass got point wait hmm Falls
faster than you think
yeah it was fast he's coming at you oh
no not today oh my gosh my same though
oh no my gosh oh all right this game
doesn't make me angry it just makes me
happy
you know even when things happen that's
yeah that's dad I'm not angry that this
is going down this way well just feels
so good gonna stick bold absolutely made
me angry I can say that yeah I was
[ __ ] I guess oh how could you
was it nice looking like a psychopath in
a way even when I'm run cuz I actually
did win one of those reboot what I do
just like you and me out apparently you
wonder you in a lot Bob I just got so
mad I could
l really funny okay we deliver it you
know you know it's those beautiful
salmon hat pills in the back know if L
you do that to me a couple times [ __ ]
[ __ ] they remind me of all the hills
that we saw today while we were driving
and also the hills on that last location
the kind yeah there you go there you go
night Anna Korea oh wait oh wait oh wait
holy jesus I'm gonna god wait about you
think oh my god don't come around now
this I know ha 2 inches at a time
oh that that block oh I know right it's
all gonna be a disappoint it makes me
want to applaud a lot oh man that was a
well thought couple of matches Easons
alright so now it's it's it's just with
bobbing with yes whatever gonna let go
door right here yeah Bob and wait turn
we take some getting used to being on
this side now ha [ __ ] alright there we
go there we go oh yeah yeah so nice to
be able to go all the way back to the
wall I know right oh not like this
mm-hmm when I save ah nah [ __ ] when I go
up that's I'm bad at the up/down
controls is my legal yes gotcha he
should know you guys ketchup on your
neck I can't do it neck ball
coordination
haha no that was my trickshot and
everything
Cathy didn't work yes score on yourself
do it for me do it whoa thank you well
let's do that on purpose
Trixie Trixie [ __ ] crab Wow
I'm a wizard apparently well okay I'm
still look shocked yeah I mean I don't
know why that's shocking when looking at
all the necks and extendable legs but of
shocking if you want to do something
hard enough it will happen with our and
that's what we learned here to do deal
with a hand with your uh glitch hey good
game YouTube that's where your dick
comes out right the front of your chest
full extension maybe those legs look a
bit next time oh that's not what I
thought was gonna happen
nothing oh geez whoa this came out who
look bald over there a little bit there
no [ __ ] no no no no now we're back to
business
no I'm so [ __ ] aren't so far wall
sucks that I don't know how to [ __ ]
play in that spot nail it look this is
waiting for the magical transporting
Nets yep
no not again Oh
[Music]
okay that was a great sir that's great
sir oh I don't like that yeah
finding your way you went to the net
once give me a break
that's my only point humble giraffe that
was giraffe all about championship 2016
no I don't like fillets on a bleep
lesson I had no idea was going to like
that so uh yeah thank you everybody so
much for watching we really hope you
enjoyed that because we had a delightful
time playing that I feel so good right I
think this was a free game right it was
free on a video it was like a pay your
own way gana game I think we chipped in
20 bucks for it yeah you guys don't have
to pay anything or pay something to
developer this is really charming game I
like it a lot I think they could improve
it and add a lot more features to it it
could be a really cool experience so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let us know we thought down the comments
below check out their channels in the
description and as always we will see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]